so you began between us with what was it
25,000 and then you raised an additional
14,000 on Kickstarter and now if we
understand this correctly it wasn't
until three days before the production
was over that you had actually had
enough financing to pay your cast and
crew yeah something like that yeah
that's it that's about yeah that's about
the right story but it kind of goes back
a few years we were hoping to make this
movie originally and I think I first got
together with Joe in 2006-2007 we were
hoping to make it in 2008 for two or
three million dollars you know that was
the goal I aim high with your budget
right and cuz you never know you may get
lucky and you know it was kind of in the
era of squid in the whale and you know
indie movies you could get made for that
um it wasn't so crazy anyway and we were
getting close to that point we were
getting a great cast because at that
point you're offering some real money I
mean not real money in the sense that we
didn't have it but it's financed
contingent money but anyway we were
getting it out to good actors and we're
getting a great cast but the but then
the economy as you well know tanked in
fall of two thousand eight and there was
no way you could raise millions or
thousands or even hundreds or tens of
dollars for any film at a budget level
for at least six more months or so so
luckily for me that happened to coincide
with remember was also during the
election campaign of 2008 with a side
project that i was doing here in the
garage which was with another filmmaker
who was staying here for about five
months at least in gaytown gorlin
another Slamdance guy and he and I were
doing this completely unrelated project
it was about a washington-based pundit
and originally was a series of short
films then it was a TV pitch and then we
kind of were incubating this character
his name is Martin eisenstadt and online
we gave him a blog and website and he
the and people in the media started to
believe he was real and so he there was
a lot of press about this at the time
and it kind of culminated with sarah
palin not knowing that africa was a
country or no not knowing it was a
continent she said it was a country she
really did say but our character took
credit for being the source of that
story anyway MSNBC have breaking news
but they had egg on their face because
he wasn't real and they were saying he
was the source of the story anyway long
story short New York Times did a big
half page profile of us and the next day
we got a book offer so when presented
from a very prestigious New York
publisher for our stress to row and so
when presented with the option do you
keep not getting paid to not direct a
movie or do you get paid to write a book
ones wife tells you to write the book
and so we did that a time and I wrote
this but you know we took a complete
hiatus off of between us he was trying
to get a feature of his made at the time
as well and and we wrote the book we had
a great time in the book tour it was
very critically acclaimed it sold well
it was you know very successful we went
back to pitching it's a TV show and
actually came very close to a deal with
Ashton Kutcher's company was going to
produce it CBS Studios was behind it was
going to be on Showtime and then the
deal fell through because one executive
got fired or something yeah and so it
was like oh huh so much for our TV
career but my old my previous casting
director from open house Liz dress key
said you know what why don't we go back
to between us at the end of the day it
was four people in two rooms how hard
could it be lets you know we know how to
make these micro budget movies let's do
that so she put in a little bit of money
now and came on as a producer we raised
some money on facebook and this is early
years of Kickstarter and we did a
Kickstarter campaign and and that was
enough to you know so by the time we had
around 40 or so thousand dollars 45
something
range that was enough to set a start
date I knew we could always make
something at that level and so so we
said we went back to the agents managers
we are casting with originally and said
okay well the script hasn't changed we
never rewrote the script to be a lower
budget maybe we should have but we
didn't and the parts are the same so if
you liked it before and your actors
liked it before they're going to like it
now we're just not paying them really
you know we'll pay them a hundred
dollars a day and we had enough to we
had enough to afford that we didn't have
enough to pay the crew Wade enough to
feed the actors as long as I didn't have
peanut allergies because then we
couldn't give them peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches so that's always the
first question to ask more gluten yeah
gluten yeah now that would have tanked
but thankfully actors don't eat I mean
it's axiomatic in this town like actors
I mean they don't eat carbs at all and I
don't think they eat anything I don't
you know I don't know how it works with
him so you know feeding them is actually
fairly easy but um sorry but yeah we and
then we were able to find a crew that
was willing to work for free we said
look we're gonna keep raising my you
know and and we were raising money and
you know until we didn't need to but but
you know if you want to work on this
movie don't expect to get paid if it
happens great but don't expect it and
luckily in LA you can find enough really
good crew people that will work on a
movie like this so we had an amazing
cinematographer Nancy Schreiber divide
meted Slamdance who said an ASC
cinematographer she's only I think like
the third woman that was ever in the ASC
and cheese you was a DP on visions of
light which is great documentary about
cinematographers anyways he's Ward
winning filmmaker and so she came on
board and she was teaching class at AFI
so she brought in a lot of her students
who worked on it and you know a lot of
people just want to work with her and
people knew me through Slamdance they
saw the actors like okay this is
something to to jump in on anyway and in
the end we did find an investor that
came in for you know roughly two-thirds
of the budget and that his check only
cleared the third to the last day of
shooting but that was enough time to pay
pay the crew at least some of the crew I
still haven't gotten paid some other
people have
and you know and we finished and was
enough to finish the film so it sounds
like there was an initial 25,000 put up
then you raise some money on facebook
and then Kickstarter and then well that
first 25,000 I wasn't even that much i
think it's like with 20 in the end came
from a couple individual people liz and
then two people that were friends on
facebook but like I one of them was
someone I knew from high school I hadn't
talked to her in you know 20 years at
least a lot more than that you know and
another was another indie filmmaker I
had no idea he had money you know I
would give it to me so it is just and I
was like oh this okay this kind of crowd
sourcing is working nicely so let and
then Kickstarter was happening in a
friend of mine had done Kickstarter he
said yeah you know you can you can raise
a good 10 grand or so on there this was
back in 2010 you said that you did the
Kickstarter campaign that's that yeah
yeah 2010 fall of 2010 we did that shows
his way before the whole Veronica breath
you know raised two million dollars cuz
you've got a movie star oh how hard
could it be you know it's like now
$10,000 was a doable goal and you know
achievable hard work to get it you know
it's not easy but you know we did it we
and we did some unique things with it in
how we promoted it but also I put our
business plan I embedded it as a PDF on
to the Kickstarter page kind of as a
almost a Trojan horse so people wanted
to give substantially more money but do
it as an investment they could find the
PDF so that so what happened was that
even though we only raised about ten
thousand dollars on Kickstarter per se
it led to us getting another 20 or
25,000 kind of ultimately be on
Kickstarter you know but more
importantly I mean I always tell people
kickstart it's called kick starter it's
not called kick finisher I mean it's
really there to get the ball rolling and
then how you take it from there is up to
you but I think the most important
person of all the 84 backers that you
know
we found on Kickstarter you know the
most important person in Vince's
yourself you know because it forces you
to you know this whole process forced me
to do a business plan to do a pitch
video and and and you know the hardest
person to convince to make a movie is
it's always yourself everyone else
they'll believe you you know but but you
know better especially after it's used
third or fourth film did you have a plan
B or C or D if that money didn't come in
probably i hadn't i always have plan b c
d and he yeah usually an effort orgy
along the way yeah no definitely and I
mean there were all kinds of odd people
that wanted to give us money that we
didn't take because there were too many
strings attached and Russian mafia
girlfriends involved and you know I mean
all kinds of weird things but you know
at some point you take it you know so I
mean in the end we were very lucky like
all the money kind of came with you know
I mean I'm have wonderful investors and
they've all been incredibly supportive
you